well another big development in the
fight against covet 19 moderna
announcing it is requesting emergency
fda approval of its vaccine candidate
today
and once it's approved could be shipped
out within 24 to 48 hours let's bring in
health and human services secretary alex
azar mr secretary it's always good to
see you sir thank you
for coming on this morning i was
interested i i was kind of looking at a
at a sound bite a quote that uh your
assistant human
health and services secretary of brett
gerward the admiral said yesterday i
want to
play this and get your response on the
other side watch
if we can immunize for impact that is
immunize those groups that are at the
highest risk like long-term care
facilities
the elderly minorities on we can
absolutely get 80 percent of the benefit
of the vaccine by only immunizing a few
percent of the population
immunized for impact mr secretary is he
saying that we don't all need this
vaccine
what he's talking about is prioritizing
because i wish we have you know 330
million doses on day one
upon approval but even with the
incredible work of president trump and
operation warp speed and
starting manufacturing in the early days
of these programs
we're going to have maybe 40 million
doses of vaccine by the end of this year
and then keep producing of these
different vaccines
and keep producing over the course of
months so we want to make sure those
first vaccines the first weeks go to
those most vulnerable those where you
have the biggest
impact on saving lives and also
protecting those who are most at risk
like our frontline health care workers
taking care
of covid patients yeah let's put these
on the screen because you
talk about the priority list and i want
to kind of run these down just her
audience is clear
health care personnel workers in
essential and critical industries
people at high risk for severe coven 19
illness due to underlying medical
conditions
people 65 years and older so the
question is
modernists saying look once they give
approval
we've got 24 48 hours we'll get this
stuff distributed
how long before the first injections
happen sir
uh well as you said it'll ship within 24
hours after
fda approval and then really it's going
to be up to our nursing homes our
hospitals our pharmacies to get that
dispense so
it really could be within within days of
fda approval we'll start seeing vaccines
in people's arms which
is frankly incredible think about this
10 months into this pandemic hitting our
shores
thanks to what president trump has done
here we believe we're going to have
people getting vaccinated
millions of people before christmas this
year it's just
unheard of in the history of public
health this accomplishment
24 to 48 hours after fda approval when
is the fda
going to approve this how long will this
process take could it take
a day two days how long so
pfizer submitted their application a
week ago and the fda said they'll hold a
public advisory committee hearing on
december 10th and if everything is on
track
fda could approve within days of that
hearing and then moderna
they file today and there'll be an
advisory committee for them
likely december 17th is what the company
has announced
and again it could be within days of
that public advisory committee that fda
grants approval if the data all
all confirms the way it's looking and
the mordarana data today
incredible 30 000 people in that
clinical trial and they just released
their full results 94
effective it's unbelievable well the
yeah the numbers are astonishing the
question is how do you get people to
take it this gallup poll is saying that
four in
ten americans don't want it how do you
convince people mr secretary
that this is the way to go well i think
some of those surveys were conducted
earlier
when there was a political campaign
going on and frankly a lot of people
were jumping in bed with the anti-vax
crowd and
denigrating or the vaccine work for for
other purposes
now i think we are all coming together
and saying 94 95
effective vaccines we need to rally
around this and convince people
that these vaccines are going to really
can can protect you
and can protect our country and get us
back to normal
and how many people do you have to
convince lastly sir i've got very little
time but but listen to 4 out of 10 let's
say it's 3 out of 10 now
how do you convince them uh well the
process is what's going to convince them
i believe it's going to show that it was
independent the data is incredibly
strong
and then they're going to get experience
as we protect our most vulnerable
protector healthcare workers people are
going to see this they're going to see
the effect
and they're going to want want it
themselves and we're going to work to
convince them of that
it's moving very rapidly health and
human services secretary alex azar mr
secretary thank you for joining us
thank you trace